brought to you by watchdogs to hack
everything available in consoles
November 15th and on PC November 29th
what sucks to uh sponsoring us this week
and since the game takes place in a
recreation of San Francisco and a pretty
nice one at that I thought we'd take a
look at five of the best depictions of
real world locations in video games
Seattle may not be the first city that
comes to mind when you're planning a
trip around America but after playing in
from the second Sun you may change your
mind on that one
of course Seattle is quite a bit more
under martial law from the government
DUP agency wanting the conduits than in
real life but the open-world action game
does a good job of showcasing the city
anyway developer Sucker Punch
productions is actually located in
Seattle and it appears to have been
pretty important to them to do justice
to the city's recreation now just by
chucking in the Space Needle and saying
see it's the Apple the game also
features the Pike Place Market the post
alley gum wall and plenty of other
landmarks it's also fortunate that
you're riddled with superpowers that
lets use up all over the city quite
quickly le noir was actually developed
by Australian studio Team Bondi but a
lot of attention to detail was put in to
make sure that the game emulated 1947
Los Angeles quite apart from recreating
the city the game uses a noir aesthetic
reminiscent of 1940s crime film and even
gives you the option to play in black
and white the game has a mode that lets
you freely roam the city and check out
familiar landmarks while engaging in
optional activities Team Bondi used
aerial photographs to model the city
even going to the effort of
incorporating traffic patterns and
public transport route of course some
artistic license was taken in creating
the city but the effort to incorporate
significant realism was extended to the
cases you can investigate which old
features some realized elements that
were reported in newspaper articles at
the time now onto something completely
different sleeping dogs wasn't just a
notable for being a critically acclaimed
action game it also does a pretty lovely
job of recreating contemporary Hong Kong
Hong Kong feels totally alive in
Sleeping Dogs as the devs put in loads
of effort to ensure everything from the
massive bank of china tower to the
sights and sounds of the busy streets
was exactly what you'd expect of Hong
Kong develop a united front Games
visited the city to conduct field
research for the visual environments and
sound designers put awake in Hong Kong
and took over 20,000 photos as
references the studio also conducted
interviews as inspiration for the game's
narrative and
to define why you end up with this kind
of an intense high-octane action film
filter over Hong Kong but it's still
very much exudes the flavor of the city
there are so many Assassin's Creed games
that could be on this list in fact I
think this list could be made up
entirely of Assassin's Creed games but
I'm gonna keep it to one so let's talk
syndicate syndicate is arguably the
result of Ubisoft building and
rebuilding on their experience in
creating living and breathing worlds
that recreate iconic slices of history
the 2014 action-adventure Thurs you into
London at the tail ends of the
industrial revolution where you control
the Frey twins Jacob and Evie Victorian
London consists of seven bars and it's
far larger than previous entries in the
series the city is thriving and consists
of lots of lovely little touches from
the era such as a group of people
playing a full game of cricket in the
park syndicate also includes notable
figures like Charles Dickens Karl Marx
and Florence Nightingale you can explore
the city by riding in carriages or
parkouring your way around the rooftops
this is the second screed after all
you'll get to explore and climb all over
to Paul's Cathedral the Tower of London
and Buckingham Palace finally we're
going back to San Francisco a driver San
Francisco that is I know it's not GTA or
fallout for the Last of Us but drive to
San Francisco does a really great job of
combining iconic SF landmarks with an
approximation of the layout of the city
the Ubisoft developed racing game had
one of the largest driving environment
created at the time the SF recreation
has around 208 miles of roads and
depictions of the baybridge as well as
parts of Marin County and Oakland of
course as the name implies you'll be
racing through the streets and taking in
the sights so just like in GTA 5 s fo LA
or Mafia 3 solutions to New Orleans that
you should feel pretty damn immersed
those are my picks but do let me know
your favorites that I miss out on
mentioning and I will see you again soon
you